I met you over 15 years ago you came on
the show and you were promoting dude
where's my car yeah in Nuevo York in
Nueva York which and I maintain that is
one of my favorite titles for a movie
ever
it's dude where's my car Pootie Tang are
like up there fighting is there any
chance you guys would ever make a sequel
there there's a script for it there is
actually a script it's called seriously
dude where's my car
which is the appropriate ID that your
perfect sequence we've just never it's
never got home yet it hasn't gotten to a
place where like people are like yeah
let's make it right right I mean I would
do it Charlie I'm Scott's like all
jacked up no no right now like I haven't
seen him lately but I saw I looked up a
picture of him the other day and he was
like so buff right then I'm afraid he's
like the rock like yeah like two SEC's
right right he can't play that character
anymore that's too sexy yeah if you guys
if you guys wait long enough there will
be a new motivation for not knowing
where your car is yeah you'll be too old
to remember where's my car where's your
car it's gotta be somewhere and Who am I
you